同学们好啊，又上课了。
上节课咱们。
剖袭烂片来的。
是吧。
以战国为例。
偷析了一下烂片。
也想了想解决了办法，我也布置了作业，大家可以自己练习练习，好吧。
学习这个东西啊，你就得多练多写。
这玩意儿就跟。
你的飞行员学开飞机一样，对吧？
你学会各种。
技巧知道每个按钮作用之后呢，你得有多少多少个。
小时的那个那个什么飞行量，你才能。
毕业才能拿证是吧？咱这编剧也是呀。
我感觉啊。
嗯。
50万，比如说你没有个50万字的磨合期是吧？是不行的。所以大家多写啊，上节课的内容里边啊。
呃，我不知道大家记不记得，我给大家讲过。
你判断一个片子或者一个剧本故事。
是好还是不好的时候，可以从。
四个方面去看。
上节课跟大家讲了四个方面，分别是。
结构。
元素。
情感。
和情绪。
就说一个片子拍出来也好，或者是一个剧本写出来也好，你都可以从这四个方面。
去卡一卡呃这个这个完成的怎么样，对吧？是不是个好东西，结构是啥呢？结构就是我们常说的你的故事类型。
你的设定与对抗对吧？你的世界设定，你的人物设定，你的规则设定，然后你的对抗你都做了哪些对抗，谁跟谁对抗？
然后呢。
你如果别人问你写了个啥故事，这个电影讲了个啥故事，你用两三句话讲给别人听的时候，你说的那几句话往往就是结构。
往往就是结构。
这个呢。
其实是一个故事的根本。
而且我还说过一个好故事，一个好作品啊，它的结构往往是简单的，干净而有力。
比如说。
加勒比海盗。
加勒比海报的结构简单说，不就是带着一个坏人去做好事吗。
主角是特纳，你是个好人，你想去救你。
呃，女神伊丽莎白嘛，但是呢你不认路啊，你出海去也不是你强项啊，你咋去呢？
这有个海盗是吧？不是个好东西。但是呢出海这件事情。
你又离不开他。
所以你带着一个坏人不得已，逼不得已带着一个坏人去做好事，这就是加勒比海盗的结构。
那你自然而然就能想象出来，那肯定会有很多的故事，他俩肯定会记个而而且各自有各自的招，各自有各自的目的，到哪里翻脸，到哪里再重新合力对付共同的对手，对吧？很明显就是就是。
就很干净很有力的一个结构。那么好的一个电影故事，其实结构就是这么简单。
你不觉得这个跟去年的那个恶人传一模一样吗？
韩国那个电影恶人传马东锡的。
一模一样，从结构角度啊。
再是说咱们课上讲过的阿凡达。
阿凡达不就是一个。
讲一个。
齐强的两面半就中间人嘛，他你到底是地球人还是外星人？你到底哪头的？就是一个中间人的故事，中间人的故事也非常非常多呀，哪吒什么的，我是人还是摸是吧？这个东西都很多的，结构呢差不多。
所以说这个东西啊是往往是我们第一个需要确定的。你这个结构到底有没有力量？
合不合理，有没有劲儿值不值得讲？
这是第一个。
然后元素是啥呢？
元素啊就是你。
这个剧本故事里面具体的那些。
写具体情节的时候。
你情节的。
真实感。
冲击力、想象力对吧？是看那个的。
比如说啊。
比如说像。
那种。
碟中谍和007之类的那种片子，你看那种片子就看啥，你肯定不看结构，或者说主要不是看结构。因为它结构你哎呀都就就它肯定会战胜坏人的，对吧？就就那个结构呢往往它没什么花了，你看元素，它又有什么新道具了。
对吧。
然后呢，他又用什么招来战胜那些坏蛋？那些坏蛋又给他制造了什么样的障碍，给我们的那个那个一son碟中谍里面的一son制造了什么样的障碍？
这医生到底这次要爬楼还是要钻地道？
还是要扒在飞机门上。
这些就是元素，就是你的想象力。
你具体的每一场戏。
视觉冲击冲击力，这就是元素。你这种片子你看这个就够了。
你就爽了，实际上实际上你就爽了，你就很开心了，对吧？所以说这是元素，往往也很重要的这个呢。
也是我们吃我们编剧。
基本功的是你的细活的。
你说我设计了一个很好的结构，很好的对抗，然后具体事儿你写不出来了，对吧？你说我写一个哎呀，胡八一去盗墓，我们肯定爱看呀，盗墓片谁不爱看，但具体幕里有些什么样的机关？
对吧有些什么样的那个那个个破解方式，胡八一用什么方式去破解这些具体的玩意儿，这就是元素。
这就是元素，每个片子对吧？
嗯。
你期待看到的元素不一样，但是呢。
少了肯定不行，你得满足他。当然了，我上节课也说过啊，我说结构完完全全是我们编剧的事儿。但像元素这类呀，它不一定就全是我们的。
呃，不一定全是我们的活了，还有很多视觉上的东西，特效上的东西，或者是。
传设上的东西对吧？都有演员表演上的东西。
都有。
这是第二个方面衡量一个作品是不是成功。然后第三个方面就是情感。
一个片子或者一个故事，有没有让你动情，那也是很重要的嘛。
你你你这这个你看一个故事也好，你看一个片儿也好，不动感情，那说明这个片儿这这也是不行的对吧？也是不行的。
大部分片子里面都是要动感情的。然后情感呢我们说。
基本上就是。
靠B故事。
对吧我们说B一故事是是是管情感的。
管情感，那就是看你的B故室设计的好不好，扎不扎实。
能不能让观众产生？
人类共同的情感。
对吧人类共同的情感。
然后最后一个呢是情绪。
情绪。
比如说。
你这个片子啊。
结构也不咋地，元素也一般，情感好像也没没那么整。但是呢你一直让观众很紧张啊。
对吧他虽然没有产生情感，但是又很有情绪啊，他很紧张啊。
那你这片子哎。
我也算你牛逼，或者你这个片子啊一直张光照片很酷。
是吧。
或者让观众害怕那恐怖片，恐怖片那种从头到尾吓人的那种也有。
你要是能下下来。
也可以。
当然了啊，这四个方面最好都做的。
呃，差不多最好都做好。
但是在实际操作中啊，我说啊一般一一个一个成品，如果有两样做的比较好，基本上也就合格了，基本上也就合格了。当然我们要追求追求都做好。
然后呢。
上节课讲完之后呢，很多同学对这个呢就比较感兴趣，觉得哎确实好像是这么去衡量一下一个剧本或者一个电影，挺有用的，也他们也会拿着去衡量自己的东西。然后有同学就想让我给大家讲一讲。
着重讲一讲情绪。因为他提问了这个东西，他说你看啊结果我们知道我们其实啊其实我们。
在课上绝大部分时间里面讲的知识都是关于结构的。
对吧大部分时间吧都是讲的是关于结构的元素呢。
我基本上就教不了你了。
需要靠你自己去积累。
需要靠你训练你的想象力，你的观察力，你的联想能力，你的类比能力，对吧？或者是你收集素材的能力。
你你整理素材库的能力。
这个呢主要靠你自己，我只能给你方法。然后情感呢其实就是B故事上的事情，大家也比较明确什么样的事情能激发情感。因为关于AB故事呢，我们讲的也不少了，关于情绪呢？哎，有同学就提出来了，说老师你可不可以怎么调动观众情绪。
怎么控制这个观影情绪，可不可以给我们一些方法和规范？
我觉得这个问题提的相当好，我们这节课就来着重说一下这个。
情绪。
咱们以后上课啊其实都应该这样，同学们多提出一些有质量的问题。
对吧你们啥不懂告诉我，我我我就及时给大家讲一讲，这非常好啊。因为提问题我们都是班级群里面的同学提的。
非常好非常好啊。
咱们现在有二十几个班，对吧？今年招了二十几个班，然后我就观察这些班里的同学。
我就发现啊。
嗯。
认真学习的同学啊，大约占一半吧，大约占一半儿。所以我我那天还开玩笑呢，我说我们的同学分两种。
一半是学习组的，就是认真的学编剧的。还有一半呢是气氛组的，就是天天在里边扯淡，天天搞气氛。
也可以对吧？因为他不一定每个同学都非要把这个写作要把编剧啊当做自己的职业嘛，当做一个爱好，当做一个兴趣，或者当做一个副业都可以啊，怎么学都可以，气氛组就气氛族。我知道你们喜欢扯淡也可以，天天问啊，老师这个呃这个片子怎么你怎么看？老师编剧能挣多少钱，一般问这种问题了，都是不好好学习的。
老还问这些问题。
但是学习组啊也不是说每个同学都都让我省心。我跟大家说啊，就是学习组的这类同学。
嗯，向我提问最多的。
问题其实不是关于知识的，是啥，你知道吗？
就是最多的一类问题啊是这么说的，一般是这么一个对话，就跟我说，老师，我是你的学生，我是什么什么什么情况，我非常喜欢您的课。
我太爱您的课了，您的课这个给我指明了方向。然后我说哎那很好，那就那就学吧，对吧？他说老师我天天在网上白嫖您的课，对吧？您的课也不收费。哎，我觉得特别不好意思，哎，我说没事没事。
学到知识就可以啊，他又说老师。
我能不能到您身边去学习，我就跟在您的身边跟您学习吧。
我要求特别低，管吃管住就可以了。
我哎想我就哎，我就不觉得不对，我说咱捋一捋啊，咱捋一捋这个事儿啊。
你白嫖我的课。
已经有点不好意思了。
你还想吃我呢。
你想吃我的。
什么情况？
而且关键问题我说了啊。
这是最多的一类问题。
就跟我说这句话的人是最多的。
我不知道你们是受了什么。
是郭德纲那儿的规矩干扰了你们吗？
我我不太了解这种情况。
回头问问郭老师，他那儿。
就是来一些人吃吗？对吧？都来吃，我吃不消呀，是不是同学们心情我可以理解啊，我明白你们的意思，心情我可以理解。其实主要是。
明白这份同学的意思啊，其实他们没有恶意啊，并不是说他们没有饭吃下来吃我的。其实我我理解想让我带他们入行嘛。
这种心情可以理解啊，因为。
你如果有这个影视梦，然后又在行内人的话，确实没抓没唠，找不到人帮你，确实没抓没落。
但是咱们课上已经无数次说过这个事儿了啊，包括直播的时候，我也说过这个事儿。呃，首先呢你得先好好学习，你如果有。
干这行的能力了。
学会本领了。
入行就不难了。因为。
才华和努力是很稀缺的。
很稀缺的。
就拿咱这个课来说，你也可以对吧？就好好学，然后好好考试。当然因为最近工作忙，考试好久没考了啊。
尽快组织吧，你通过学考试，然后呢进到实验班，实验班的话，我一看你差不多了，然后我就把你的简历帮你去去去去推销推销，或者你的剧本，我帮你去推销推销都可以，没什么问题，对吧？第二呢，你如果那个那个那个学的差不多了，你还可以去。
投简历找工作嘛，对吧？我不是说了嘛？你那些影视公司，你不一定看人家招编剧，你再去人家招策划，招助理，你就先去嘛。
去了之后，你只要进到这个圈了，人家一看哎呦。
这小子还能写。
那多好会倒会写，会剪，那就很那你就很快就上手了，没有人拦着你，真的，你只要能干，绝不拦着你，你能干活，人家干嘛要拦着你？
对不对？就像我说为什么我鼓励大家学编剧。
码字儿一个晚上8000字，熬着不睡觉，码字儿这个事儿啊没人跟你抢，就是你要真能写的话，他们不跟你抢，你放心吧，没人拦着你，好吧。
啊，接着说咱们课程啊。
嗯，讲一讲这个情绪，其实也就是观众的这个叫。
观影情绪对吧？
观影情绪这个东西咋讲嘞？也有办法，其实也是有一定的规律和规范的。这节课呢咱就试着跟大家。
剖析一下。
首先。
这节课的内容是我的观点。
第二，这节课的内容我们讲的是一般情况，大多数情况，所以供大家参考。好吧。首先研究一下啊，就是这个情绪啊，情绪跟情感啊就差一个字，但其实是不一样，同学们都能理解，对吧？情感啊更那个那个那个深一点。
对吧那种爱呀，恨呐那种。
情绪呢更更更更更更表面一点。咱这么说吧，情感不是B故事管的吗？情感是B故事上管的情绪呢就是A故事上管的。
表层的B股市内在的A股是表层的对吧？情绪呢是A故事上管的。
更直接的那些情绪上的刺激，就是A故事上。那么既然是A故事上，那我们还是拉一下这个我们的。
轴对吧？我们每次都是。
每次都是轴上键嘛，对吧？我们的私目式对吧？
这个呃。
几层。
转合私募式。
那其实这就是我们的A故事嘛，我们的A故事上的一个脉络。
我们就试着在这个轴上剖析一下，在整个这个影片过程中，我们的观众的观影情绪。
一般状态是一个什么状态，我们怎么去，我们知道他这里需要是什么状态，我们就不就知道应该怎么去引导他了吗？对吧？首先起点这个位置。
我们说。
注意力。
就在这个位置呀，我们着重要搞的是观众的。
那注意律具体是啥情绪呢？这个就不一定了，它是个综合情绪。
所以这里呢就没有具体的情绪的规定了。
只要是强烈的直接的刺激吸引大家的注意力。
就可以了。
比如说。
最常用的啊是让你兴奋。
兴奋是一种情绪啊。
五戏开场。
咣咣打。
枪战或者武侠在天上飞，在在天上砍。
对打你看啊很多电影开场。
都是这么开的，开场是在打。
你他妈还没看清谁跟谁打呢，对吧？其实也不知道谁跟谁打，也不知道哪个是正义，哪个是邪恶。但是他开场才打几分钟，为啥呢？他就是要你的注意力。
所以说情绪的第一第一步。
就是给你一个。
强烈的直接的刺激。
以兴奋对吧？以兴奋为例。
他老吸引你注意力的。
目的。所以第一个情绪我们暂定为兴奋。
是吧。
当然也可以试其他的啊，让你害怕也可以啊，对吧？
让你那个。
还有很多戏开场，喜欢那个美女，很多网大开场第一场戏，美女露着大腿是吧？很妖娆，虽然也不知道他是干嘛的，搞不好他跟这个故事也没关系，但是也有很多，对吧？
我们公司出的很多房大爷就是这样，但是严格说这个属于兴奋是吧？跟看武的武戏是一个道理。所以说第一个情绪是兴奋。
然后吸引了你的注意力之后呢，第二步要干的是啥呢？
是让你入洗。
就一个故事来说啊，把你注意力拿下了之后，第二步要做的是入戏。那入戏这里。
入戏不是一个情绪啊，那入戏这里。
的情绪是什么呢？
讲过的。
三种。
连。
哎。
气。
我们写故事的时候，从人物的角度，这里要干什么来着？让观众跟入戏观众跟你共情，你不是要可怜可信可爱吗？可以去怜，可以去爱，可以去信吗？那从观众观影的角度，他这里。
给到你的情绪，不就是连你爱你信你吗？
是不是不就是连你爱你信你吗？
所以说第二步情绪是这个。
这是第二步的情绪。然后。
入完戏之后。
第三步马上要给到的情绪就到这个第一幕衔接这里了，基本上到这里了。
我们说在这个位置，我们要做的事情是什么来着？
是让观众开始产生预期。
对吧在这个位置啊，你需要开始让观众产生预期了。因为这里你不就上路了吗？这个位置不是上路的吗？背上小包离家出走的那个位置吗？
就开始让观众产生预期，在预期这里一般会有什么样的情绪呢？那期呀首先得有期待吧。
期待吧。
对吧或者是憧憬。
跟期待一个意思，但是比较难写。
那还有期待往往是往好的方面期待。那有时候而有时候不计不也会是那个担忧嘛。
有。
优势树心款哦对。
但忧嘛没有票。
担忧嘛，就是说期待担忧其实是一个意思，只不过是一个往上一个往下，对吧？所以你看骑的这部分。
观众的观影情绪兴奋。
联系爱，然后期待或担忧是一个意思。
然后接下来呢。
接下来呢。
接下来接的是欢乐呀。
欢乐呀。
你忘了这儿是什么了吗？
这是游戏啊，游戏时光上路先游戏。
你得欢乐呀。
对不对？也就是游戏这里对吧？带来的是欢乐。
然后接下来呢，我们说接下来在这个部部分啊还会有。
这个这个这个。
伙伴啊。
爱情啊。
这个。
失恋呀。
新道具呀。
对不对？
那这里还会有什么？
还会有一个。
期待的。
放大。
期待的放大。
然后或者是担忧的放大一样。
期待放大，担忧放大。
我们说那我这儿已经做了期待担忧了。老师，你在这儿让我做另外一种程序，叫期待放大，我不会做呀。我跟你说，期待放大导致什么？一般保持思考。
我就思考。
就是观众开始思考这个角色的未来和他做这件事做的这些决定的对错问题。
这就是期待或者担忧变大导致的事情。
他对你担忧大劲了，他开始思考他要不要跟你一伙了，他开始思考你小子。
啊。
对不对呀？你啊。
是吧。
就是思考这里要让观众思考。
好吧，然后我们说在这个位置，我们说这是终点位置啊，终点位置啊，对不对？在这里我们说是。
第一次小满足。
因为它是终点嘛。
虚假的胜利会失败啊。
那也是剧情的第一次小满足呀，那啥叫满足呢？
啥叫满足呢？
啥都啥情绪能得得到一定的小满足呢？比如说高兴。
得到了一个满意的结果嘛？你以为满意的结果啊，如果是假设利的话，那不就是你以为观众以为的满意结果吗？暂时的满意结果，这就是其实就是高兴一下，或者是惊讶一下。
因为我们说你呈现给观众的东西啊，是他想要的，但是不是以他想要的方式给他的。
那么这里有可能会有个小惊讶。
小惊讶，对吧？
然后如果是一次虚假胜利呢，这里说不定还是个悲剧呢。
还有悲伤呢？
对吧所以说这里呢就是一个小满足，会有高兴、惊讶、悲伤这类的情绪。
这类情绪。
然后我们说进到转这里，马上记录刚才这个小曼足。
是假的。
是假的，事情没有这么简单，我们要重新调整方向，这个不对的没搞定。那这里呢转这里一上来会接一个生气。
会接一个升旗。
我们这里说的所有的情绪是观众的情绪啊，不是角色的情绪，大家一定搞清楚啊，不是角色在有点生气了啊，是观众生气了，观众有点生自己的气或者生角色的气，这个是都有的。观众会觉得。
错了，咱搞错了。
对吧不是这样，所以说观众在这里。
会有生气的情绪，往往在这个位置会有生气的情绪。然后接下来我们说在转这里啊。
这个这个这个我们要把主角打入谷底。很显然。
我们得难过。
悲伤难过呀，真正的难过，你你主角灵魂黑夜了呀，男二可能死了在这里，是不是男二在这死了，你不难过吗？
K三走过了65分钟了。
已经死了。
经死了。
一般男尔就是出场65分钟。
我们说男二如果跑下来开，就跟男一在一块儿一起出场的话，那他就在65分钟挂。
他如果在上路上再遇到的话，他一般就能坚持到最后。如果他从第二幕进，那一般能坚持到最后。否则你看啊我们主角自己经历现状和激励之后，踏上征途，征途遇到伙伴那里，其实就是30分钟的里啊，低故室那里开端那里，如果遇到的是伙伴，30分钟的里再遇到伙伴，你让而60分钟就死。
太快了，对吧？一般如果是这里出现的伙伴啊，就能干到底了。当然他也有可能死，但他至少能干到底能干到底。所以65分钟死的伙伴一般是开场就出的。就窝里带的我们男主窝里带的哥们在这儿死。好啊，接着说咱们的情绪啊。那在这里灵魂黑夜必然要有难过。
必然要有难过。
对吧必然难过。
然后难过之后呢。
难过之后呢。
我们的主角在这里痛定思痛吧。因为我们说灵魂黑夜呀，灵魂黑夜他要找个地儿舔舐伤口吧。
而且他在反击之前，他积蓄力量，他得想通一些事儿吧。我们说周星驰如果舔舐伤口，他肯定要翻一翻以前的那个武功秘技，降龙杀八掌，他得看会了吧。所以在这里呢在这里啊我们会接一个。
欣慰。
类似欣慰的情绪，因为下面马上要接激动。
就男主角挺身而出，决定拼了，大干一场，对吧？
是因为后面直接接激动。
对吧因为难过直些接激动太快，这儿会有一个欣慰，会有一个舔舐伤口的过程。因为在这里啊，你需要男主角沉下心来思考一些东西，拍一场那个那个那个那个。
呃，比较状态的戏，对吧？
让他思考一些东西，然后激动这里，那自然是跟。
这个这个这个对手拼了，孤注一掷，对吧？勇敢的拼了，那最后得的是。
跟这个相对的那就是。
大满足嘛。
就最终真正的满足嘛，大满足嘛。
大满族。
大满族我们说那还是这些东西了，还是这些东西了，就是。
大高兴对吧？或者是大悲伤。
当然有没有还会有惊讶的情况呢？那就是有可能再出反转。
再出反转。
我们说这就是A故事上情绪，观众的观影情绪的。
基本大点。
基本上就是这么个规律。
基本上就是那么个规。
这是事件上啊在事件发生的过程中，跟着事件观众观影产生的情绪。
我们说啊还有一种情绪，我们不能忽略的不能忽略的，我们叫。
紧张感有紧张感，这这也是一种情绪吧，往往来自于。
悬念。
有一节课我们讲过悬疑与反转呀。
很多片子要有悬念的呀，商业片子往往都有悬念的呀。
对吧你只即便不是探案片，即便不是谍战片悬大悬疑片，你也也也也应该有点。
学医的东西。
让大家紧张的东西勾着大家的。
看的东西。也就是说，如果这些。
是A故事上我们要做的事情。
那么从悬疑的角度来讲。
从悬疑的角度来讲。
我们怎么打点呢？
一般在这个位置。
在上路之前。
我们说。
在上路之前，我们把这个这个叫。
悬疑。
展开。
在上路之前，把悬疑展开，在这个位置，然后再思考这个位置。
悬疑。
加强。
悬疑加强在思考这个位置，往往是悬疑加强。因为这里有时间。
让你反思我到底做的对不对吗？结合之前的那个我一直没有解决的那个悬疑，是不是当中有问题，是不是有个秘密，我们看错了，对吧？在思考这里完全可以让悬疑加强。
在上路之前让悬疑展开，你雄赳赳气昂昂准备上路了，眼看前途一片光明，对吧？离家出走了嘛？但是其实有一个事儿，观众看到了，这个事儿有可能后面会要你的命。
但是具体怎么弄，观众也不知道，这就叫悬念嘛。
往往就放在这个位置。
上路之前对吧？我们放在期待这儿，我们对在期待这儿。
然后再。
思考这里。
悬疑加强。
学习加强，有种种迹象表明。
这个事儿要坏事儿这个事儿要坏事儿。
然后。
生气和难过。这里。
灵魂黑夜呀灵魂黑夜必然是你A故事让你栽跟头了，那也其实也就是你之前这个悬疑。
彻底给你。
报应来了这么说吧，对吧？报应来了，这个我们说悬疑是悬而未觉的定时炸弹。
这个位置我们看到炸弹了。
这个位置看到炸弹在倒计时了。
这个位置炸弹爆炸了，炸弹在这爆了爆了解决了。
然后。
作为一个优秀的悬疑。
爆了就化成灰了吗？
啊，不会的，在结局这里。
反转。
再判断再上去。
这就是。
悬疑也是一种情绪啊，让观众紧张嘛，悬疑让观众紧张，紧张也是一种情绪。就说。
还有这条线不要去把它。
不实。
明白了吧？
这就是我们。
一个正常的私幕式的片子，观众的基本的观影情绪的一个走向。我们总结出来给大家参考一下，对吧？也算是一个基本的规范吧，大差不差，基本上就是这个路子。
然后我们找一个片子来卡一卡，来对一对，看看他们是怎么做的，好吧。
我给大家找的那个。
我不知道哪一节课，反正给大家拉片的时候，我给大家讲过一个电影叫摇滚校园，你们记得吧？摇滚校园这个片子我们说剧本做的是非常漂亮的，很干净很利索。
这个这个这个。
故事我先给大家讲一下啊。
故事我给大家讲一下好故事啊，几句话就能讲清楚是吧？讲的是什么呢？讲的是一个落魄的摇滚歌手，混的很差的摇滚歌手。
边缘人，然后很穷很穷呢，然后他就冒名顶替到一个学校里面去当老师，就人家这个学校找招老师，招的不是他招的是他朋友，他因为缺钱，冒名顶替就去了。去了那之后呢，就想挣这个钱。去了之后发现哟。
这个学校是个贵族学校，贵族学校这些小孩啊。
都会搞一搞乐器的。
然后他不是被摇滚乐队给踢出来了吗？
他就发现了。
这些小孩不错呀。
精通各种乐器。
他就想组织这帮小孩儿。
唱摇滚乐搞搞一支摇滚乐队，然后呢去参加一个摇滚乐的比赛，给自己出一口恶气，然后挣挣那个奖金。
他想挣那个奖金，然后带着小孩呢去参加那个摇滚乐的比赛，就是这么一个故事。
很标准的商业片，对吧？很标准的商业片。
也挺好看的，我拉片给大家拉过，我们来看一下他的故事走向有没有满足我们这个观众的观影情绪。
我凭着回忆给大家讲啊，后期的同学我讲到哪里，你们就把这场戏剪出来，在下面给大家看一看吧啊。我凭记忆先复述一下。首先第一个部分注意力就是开场让观众兴奋，让观众注意到你这个戏。
那他这个片子。
我想你们也应该能想到他会用什么演出嘛。
摇滚乐嘛讲的是摇滚乐，那开场肯定是我们这个男主角的一场演出。确切的说是最后一场演出，在老乐队的最后一场演出。
台台上很兴奋的唱歌。
异常。
音乐。
开场跟武戏是一样的。
就是吸引你的注意力，让观众兴奋。所以第一场没毛病。
然后第二场我们是联线爱。
安静下来之后，我们的主角可怜可信可爱。
可怜他怎么做的？
让乐队K出来，这就不说了，对吧？这是肯定的。
更重要的做了一个什么啊？我在课上给大家讲过的。
没钱。
我说没钱是最容易激起共情的，因为绝大部分观众都觉得自己没钱，谁都觉得自己没钱，谁都觉得自己缺钱钱不够。所以你看他没钱没钱交房租，然后人家对他凶手恶煞，要把他赶出去，逼他交房租。
他赖呀他就赖，然后可爱有没有也有就是。
他为了把这个房租凑上。
他想把他最心爱的吉他给。
给卖了。
嗯，作为一个摇滚吉他手，这个这个吉他是他的生命啊。但是他这个这个这个。
大丈夫对吧？能屈能伸呀。
那个那个那个人家逼他交房租，他想把这个吉他给卖了。
所以让我们觉得瞬间觉得哎呦这个人物虽然可怜，但是。
你还算有所担当吧。
所以第二部分入戏。
联系爱。
就是这一部分。然后接下来呢就是产生期待和担忧。
他马上接到一通电话。
人家。
一个学校招老师，招代课老师，就顶班老师找的是呢他朋友。
他一听钱不少。
他给应下来了，他说我就是那个谁谁谁，我来吧。
然后呢，他就去这个学校当老师。你想啊你看他这个形象。
一个。
乐里勒忒的没有文化的。
不修边幅的。
地下摇滚乐吉他手去一个贵一板一眼，板板正正的贵族小贵族学校当老师，你难道没有期待和担忧吗？
你脑子里面马上就开始有预期了。我们说这里让观众产生预期啊，你马上就会预期到他那学生随便问那个数学题，他就不会了。
是不是？然后去了之后肯定要捣乱吧。
肯定要这么刘姥姥进大观园吧。
肯定跟其他老师要相处不好吧，是吧？所以你看期待和担忧，马上都有了。
他作为一个。
这样一个形象的一个相当于一个盲流吧，一个盲流去当老师，期待和担忧马上都来了。
这就是期待和担忧。然后进入到第二部分之后，我们说首先是花柳。
他去了这个学校之后，马上就开始搞笑了嘛。
肯定搞笑呀，去啥也不管，啥也不懂，开始鼓捣鼓捣这儿鼓捣鼓捣那儿，这儿捣乱那儿捣乱。我说的就是刘姥姥进大观园。第一件事情就是欢乐嘛，大家看笑话嘛，很开心，我说欢乐不是他欢乐，不是主角欢乐。我们主角四处碰壁，处处不适应。我们是说观众观影的时候很欢乐。
又看到笑话。
所以说欢乐这里。
欢来这里。
然后。
这里啊。
我们说。
期待放大。
思考中就是他发现了。
这些学生啊。
会乐器。
他就萌发了想要。
萌发了，想要那个那那个啥。
带这些学生组个乐团，组个乐队去参加比赛，赢奖金的这个念头。
期待放大。
然后我们也开始思考思考什么？我我说思考是思考什么？什么叫思考？
我刚才说了，思考其实就是你愿不愿意跟主角站在一起了。
其实有点就在这里，你开始有点觉得你小子这事儿啊，你可有点不地道是吧？就是这就叫思考。然后接下来呢他做这件事情肯定有风险的呀，让人发现了咋整？那哎。
这里得到一个小满足，他成功的组起了乐队，成功的避开了家长和校长对他的责难。因为校长和家长都差点发现这个事儿啊。
你天天排练，人家以为你上数学呢，里边叮咣的对吧？都贴死，别让隔壁听到他们在这玩乐器，还得串通所有的同学。
不能说漏嘴呀，因为不是所有同学都配合你呀，有那种爱学习，有学习组的呀，不是所有同学都是气氛组的呀，那有学习组的呀，人家要好好学习呀，对吧？
在这里呢暂时搞定小满足。
然后生气。
接下来会有生气的剧本，你你这里观众为什么生气？
就发现他为了钱把这些孩子都给出卖。
他的目的只有钱，不是带同学们去实追逐音乐梦，不是他就是为了钱，所以生气了。
然后难过是什么呢？
灵魂黑夜决裂，所有事儿都砸了，所有事儿都砸了。
比赛也参加不成了，他也被学校开除了。然后同学们呢学习也耽误了，音乐也没整上。
难过。
欣慰是什么呢？就我们的主男主角。
良心发现。
他觉得赢不赢那个奖金。
算了，钱不重要，但是孩子们的音乐梦想是真的。因为那些孩子不是为了奖金，那些孩子来找到他说哎。
老师今天不是参加比赛吗？你怎么不去呢？怎么那么怂了？他以为他已经被学校开除了嘛，他确实已经被学校开除了。但是这些孩子还惦记着他还在排练。
还想去唱歌。
欣慰，然后接下来马上激动，带着孩子冲过去，冲破阻挠，对吧？最后时间赶到，没有参赛资格就上去争取终于到台上去表演。然后表演的时候呢，不光他们表演的很成功，学校的老师家长全都来了。
全都来了。
然后在这种激动的情况下，最后获得了大满足，表演非常成功。家长们很嗨，这些贵族学校的这些学生的家长，那都是对吧？那都是硅谷精英啊，那都是律师医生的这种对吧？全都一板一眼的，但是全都被摇滚精神所感动了。
我们的男主角也找到了。
自己作为一个摇滚歌手。
最重要的使命。
就是传播摇滚精神，成为一个好的摇滚人，并不是什么奖金，并不是什么花船锦簇，对吧？然后呢，他大家都得到了大满足高兴。
你看A故事啊，我们的这个摇滚校园。
查的很准。
哎，我们再看这个悬疑，我们说摇滚校园可不是什么谍战片。
也不是什么侦探片儿，他有悬疑吗？
有权疑吗？
又骂。
首先。
我说过，基本上所有的商业片都有悬念，都有悬疑。
这个片子商业了不能再商业了，，这个故事非常商业，非常商业。
他的悬念旋疑是什么呢？我在悬念旋疑那那里第一个给大家举的例子就是假身份嘛。
就是假身份嘛，假身份就是很好用的一个悬念悬疑嘛。你看他不他这个不是个老师，他跑到那里去假装老师，这个不就是悬疑嘛？这个不就是悬念嘛？这个事情什么时候穿帮，穿不穿帮，怎么穿帮，穿帮了事之后有什么后果，不就是我们观众。
紧张的事情，担心的事情嘛，所以他的悬疑线他的悬疑线当然没有侦探片谍探片那么强。因为那些悬疑关乎生死，他这个悬疑没有那么强，但是人家也是呃这个这个这个五脏俱全的呀。
来假设问这个悬念。
是不是在这儿开始了？
他接了那封电话，决定去当。
这个贾老师悬念是不是在这开始了，在期待这里开始的对吧？然后期待放大这里，他决定利用这帮孩子去。
去去去去赢钱，就是他决定。
拿这帮孩子去去赚钱。
悬念放大，就是他这个假身份穿帮的风险变大，因为他不好好在那儿假装代课老师了，他要领着这帮学生逃课，领着这帮学生训练，领着学帮盯咣的。然后校长和其他老师都盯上他们了。所以他的假身份败露的可能性在这里放大了。
也就是这个悬念悬而未觉的这根线更细了，更要断了。定时炸弹快爆了，这里是发现定时炸弹，他决定去顶冒名顶替，发现定时炸弹。这里是定时炸弹，滴答滴答滴答开始加快了。
对吧他开始自己作死了，这里在南过这里定时炸弹爆了。
穿帮了呀，被学校开除了，就是在这里灵魂黑夜之前，灵魂黑夜或者说同步吧。
悬面爆炸。
禁定时炸弹爆炸，身份败露被开除。
被开除，我们说悬念线，你看啊。
在这个位置。
开始在这个位置滴答滴答在这个位置爆炸。我们说在很多悬念里面，它往往最后再来个反转，我们这个有吗？
我们这个悬念是什么？
他是个假老师，最后反转是什么？
他成了甄老师了嘛？对对？明白吧？
他成了真老师了。
他成为那个音乐老师了嘛。
对不对？就是说你不用去假装教数学，假装教历史了，你来教音乐不就完了吗？所以你看悬念反转又返回去了。
多漂亮的悬念。
多漂亮的旋景线。
所以说你看我们这个摇滚校园，大家如果不记得剧情，可以再去看一下。从观影情绪的角度。
卡的严死可缝，甚至连我们的这条悬疑线，他这个身份危机线卡的都很齐。
好了。
这节课就是给大家讲一下，从情绪的角度，从一个片子情绪的角度，我们既然情绪这么重要，那么在。
实际的操作中，你如何去检验你的情绪有没有到位，你就按照。
这个脉络这个表格这个规则去查一下。好吧，再次强调啊，这是一般规律。
一般规律不可能每一个片子百分之百准确。但是对于商业片来说。
差不多基本上差不多。
好吧，同学们自己体会下课吧。
嗯。
每一次。
在我两太不。
坚止切。